let me ask you about climate change
there's a let's go from the meme to the
to the profound philosophy okay the meme
was there's a clip of you talking about
climate change and saying that the
Aquaman meme uh you said that for the
sake of argument if the water level
arises five to ten feet in the next
hundred years people will just sell
their homes and move
and then the meme was sell to who uh can
you argue both sides of that the
argument that they're making is a straw
man the argument that I'm making is over
time I don't mean that if a tsunami is
about to hit your house you can list it
on eBay that's not that's not what I
mean obviously what I mean is that human
beings have an extraordinary ability to
adapt it's actually our best quality and
that as water levels rise real estate
prices in those areas tends to fall that
over time people tend to abandon those
areas they tend to leave they tend to
right now sell their houses and then
they tend to move and eventually those
houses will be worthless and you won't
have anybody to sell to but presumably
not that many people will be living
there by that point which is one of the
reasons why the price would be low
because there's no demand so it's over a
hundred years so all of these price
Dynamics are very gradual relative to
the other price Dynamics correct that's
why the joke of it of course is that
like I'm saying that tomorrow there's a
tsunami on your Source step and you're
like oh Bob will buy my house Bob ain't
gonna buy your house like we all get
that but it's a funny man I laughed at
it how is your view on climate change
the the human
um contribution to climate change what
we should do in terms of policy to
respond to climate change how has that
changed over the years I would say
the truth is for for years and years
I've believed that climate change was a
reality and that anthropogenic climate
change is a reality uh I don't argue
with the ipcc estimates I know
climatologists at places like MIT or
Caltech and they know this stuff better
than I do so you know the the notion
that climate change is just not
happening or that human beings have not
contributed to climate change I find
doubtful the question is to what extents
human beings are contributing to climate
change that 50 is it 70 is it 90 I think
there's a little bit more play in the
joints there so it's not totally clear
the one thing I do know and this I know
with with factual accuracy is that all
of the measures that are currently being
proposed are unworkable and will not
happen so when people say parent climate
Paris climate Accords even if those were
imposed you're talking about lowering
the potential trajectory of climate
change by a fraction of a degree if if
you're talking about the if you're
talking about you know Green New Deal
Net Zero by 2050. the carbon is up there
in the air and the climate change is
going to happen also you're assuming
that geopol the geopolitical Dynamics
don't exist so everybody is going to
magically get on the same page and we're
all going to be
imposing massive carbon taxes to get to
Net Zero by 2050. I mean like hundreds
of times higher than they currently are
and that's not me saying that's Cloud
Schwab saying this of the world economic
Forum who's a big advocate of exactly
this sort of policy and the reality is
that we're going to have to accept that
at least 1.5 degrees Celsius of climate
change is baked into the cake by the end
of the century again not me talking
William nordhaus The Economist who just
won the Nobel Prize in the stuff talking
and so what that suggests to me is what
we've always known human beings are crap
at mitigation and excellence in
adaptation right we are we are very bad
at mitigating our own fault we are very
good adapting to the problems as they
exist which means that all of the
estimates that billions will die that
there will be Mass starvation that we
will see the migration in just a few
years of hundreds of millions of people
those are wrong what you'll see is a
gradual change of living people will
move away from areas that are inundated
on the coast you will see people
building sea walls you'll see people
adapting new technologies to stock
carbon out of the air you will see
geoengineering right that this is the
sort of stuff that we should be focused
on and the sort of bizarre focus on what
if we just keep tossing hundreds of
billions of dollars at the same three
Technologies over and over in the hopes
that if we subsidize it this will
magically make it more efficient I've
seen no evidence whatsoever that that is
that is going to be the way that we get
ourselves out of this necessity being
the mother of invention I think human
beings will adapt because we have
adapted and we'll continue to adapt so
to the degree we invest
in the the thread of this it should be
into the policies that help with the
adaptation versus the mitigation right
sea walls geoengineering developing
technologies that carbon out of the air
again if I thought that there was more
Sort of hope for the green technologies
currently in play Then subsidization of
those Technologies I might be a little
bit more for but I haven't seen
tremendous progress over the course of
the last 30 years in the reliability of
for example wind energy uh or or the
ability to store solar energy to the
extent necessary to actually power a
grid what's your thoughts on nuclear
energy is nuclear nuclear energy is a
proven source of energy and we should be
radically
extending the the use of nuclear energy
it's one one to me that honestly this is
like a litmus test question as to
whether you take climate change
seriously if you're on right or left and
you take climate change seriously you
should be in favor of nuclear energy if
you're not I know that you're just you
have other priorities yeah the
fascinating thing about the climate
change debate is the Dynamics of the
fear-mongering over the past few decades
because uh some of the nuclear energy
was tied up into that somehow there's a
lot of fear about nuclear energy it
seems like there's a lot of social
phenomena social dynamics involved
versus dealing with just science it's
interesting to watch and if on my darker
days it makes me cynical about our
ability to use reason and science to uh
to deal with the threats of the world I
think that our ability to use reason in
science to deal with threats of the
world is almost a time frame question so
I think that we're again we're very bad
at looking down the road and saying you
know because people can't handle for
example even things like compound
interest yeah right like the idea that
if I put a dollar in the bank today that
15 years from now that's going to be
worth a lot more than a dollar people
can't actually see that and so the idea
of let's foresee a problem then we'll
deal with it right now as opposed to 30
years down the road typically we let the
problem happen and then we solve it and
it's bloodier and worse than it would
have been if we had solved it 30 years
ago but it is in fact effective and
sometimes it turns out the solution that
we're proposing 30 years in advance is
not effective and that's that's a that
can be a major problem as well well
that's then the Steel Man the the case
for fear-mongering for irrational
fear-mongering we need to be scared
shitless in order for us to do anything
so that that's that you know I'm
generally against that but maybe on a
population scale maybe some of that is
necessary for us to respond appropriate
for long two long-term threats
we should be scared jealous I don't
think that we can actually do that
though like I like first of all I think
that it's it's platonic lives are
generally bad uh and then second of all
I don't think that we actually have the
capacity to do this I think that the
people who are you know the the sort of
Elites of our society who get together
in rooms and talk about this sort of
stuff and I've been in some of those
meetings at my synagogues Friday night
actually nobody but uh but I didn't make
the joke but I'm glad you did yeah you
know I've been in rooms like Davos like
rooms and when people discuss these
these sorts of topics and they're like
what if we just tell people that it's
going to be a disaster with tsunamis and
day after tomorrow it's like you guys
don't have that power you don't and by
the way you dramatically undercut your
own power because of covid to do this
sort of stuff because a lot of the sort
of what if we scare the living hell out
of you to the point where you stay in
your own house for two years and we tell
you you can't send your kids to school
and then we tell you that the vaccine is
going to prevent transmission and then
we also tell you that we need to spend
seven trillion dollars in one year and
it won't have any inflationary effect
and it turns out you're wrong on
literally all of those things
the the last few years have done more to
undermine institutional trust at any
time in in probably American history
it's pretty pretty amazing yeah I tend
to agree with that the only thing we
have to fear is fear itself